big risk it's potentially huge reward
but it's it's a it's a big risk because
as much as they may claim that Batman V
Superman is not justice league it I mean
it is their base they're basically
opting to make the Avengers as their
second right film you know what you know
I did not see in that list Allah and
maybe I'm just remembering it wrong
Batman and Man of Steel Superman yeah
neither we're getting their own solo
moon see that's it with everybody
including us in the comic of course in
this conversation has gotten so wrapped
up and everything that hasn't been
announced I not too many people are
taking note of the fact that they're not
gonna do an actual man of steel to
they're not going to do a Batman solo
movie right I mean I was I was under the
impression that they were doing a actual
Man of Steel like solo sequel that would
be Superman versus Brainiac but if
they're folding that idea into the first
justice league movie thing I'm sure
they'll still use these actors but it's
it is a little bit odd then the two
biggest names aren't in the next five
six years aren't getting their own movie
i mean i can i can understand I mean
with with all of the filming all the
scheduling that these things are going
to be going back to back to back to back
man I mean 44 we're talking about these
solo movies involve characters that
presumably will be in all of the team up
movies in her trunk in atlanta i can see
ben affleck saying i don't want to do a
Batman solo movie between these things
I've got other projects this is entire
world he's got enough cloud that if they
decided they wanted they would kowtow to
right um so was it maybe maybe the
divisive pneus and the criticism of man
of steel plate effect on that maybe
they're like let's not rush a sequel to
this movie that might not attract the
audience weaves but maybe so
and here's another complication for the
semester six all right for for the
Suicide Squad to join the sinister squad
six suicide hers